The search for the most immersive interactive
gameplay experience is over, but the fight
for survival has only just begun.
In case you missed a few key details, here
are all the clues you need to puzzle out the
ending to Escape Room.
The premise of Escape Room revolves around
a group of strangers who receive invites to
a competitive escape game, purportedly the
most immersive experience of its kind.
The game is being put on by a company called
Minos Escape Rooms, a name that suggests this
company means business.
The name "Minos" refers to the mythical first
King of Crete, who presided over a labyrinth
to which young people would be brought for
his entertainment.
Maze-like and practically unescapable, the
participants would typically die inside the
labyrinth, killed by a monstrous Minotaur.
While the movie's escape room isn't particularly
maze-like, the idea of people being lured
there to die for others' entertainment proves
especially relevant by the time the ending
rolls around, and the true nature of the company
is revealed.
“Talk about immersive"
"what's wrong with you, that was real!"
After the escape game reveals its deadly nature,
the surviving players start to uncover what
its true purpose is.
Mike, Ben, Zoey, and Jason enter a room that's
mocked up to resemble a hospital several hospitals,
actually, with each player finding something
familiar.
They realize the setup is meant to remind
them of past traumatic experiences in which
they emerged as the lone survivors.
Zoey survived a plane crash, Jason survived
a boating accident, Mike survived a mining
accident, and Ben survived a fatal drunk driving
collision.
As Zoey describes it, they are all statistical
anomalies.
This aspect of the game is more than just
psychological.
As the game master reveals in the final chamber,
the contest was set up specifically to pit
lone survivors against each other, for the
sake of seeing what would happen when these
lucky few compete.
Upon discovering the game's true nature, something
inside Zoey snaps.
While all of the other players set about attempting
to solve a puzzle, Zoey goes berserk, and
starts smashing every camera in the room.
She guesses that the people in charge of the
game aren't just observing their play, but
actively involving themselves in it — something
that would be impossible if she takes away
their ability to watch.
"They're watching us, they know every move
that we're making.”
As poisonous gas fills the room, the other
players flee, leaving Zoey behind as she insists
on finishing the job.
She survives the gas by breathing through
an oxygen mask, knowing that no one can see
she's still alive.
When the Minos staff comes to clear out the
chamber, they assume she's dead — until
she attacks.
Danny, the avid gamer who met his end by drowning
in the cold room, previously insisted that
brute force shouldn't be necessary to win
the game.
But in this instance, it might be the only
way.
While Zoey practices her game-breaking gambit,
Ben presses forward to the final room, where
he meets a man who describes himself as the
game master.
Ben is declared the winner while the GM monologues
like a super villain, spilling all the details
of Minos' motivations.
He reveals the games are entertainment for
wealthy audiences, like gladiator fights,
with Ben's group being the latest iteration
of a long line of twisted games.
The contest, he reveals, is for the benefit
of no one but the viewers — the players
aren't allowed to win.
The game master then attempts to strangle
Ben to death before Zoey reappears and intervenes.
Together, they kill the game master, and finally
make their escape.
After Ben and Zoey leave, 24 hours pass, with
Ben being checked into a hospital for his
injuries.
When Zoey is informed that Ben is stable,
she's called away by police to assist in their
investigation.
Their findings are not encouraging.
Back at the Minos building, the company is
nowhere to be found.
The facility has been cleared out.
In a final insult, Zoey is taunted by a message
on the wall, familiar only to her, that reads
"Wootang Yu" — a mysterious name that previously
appeared in several rooms of the game.
She realizes that the nonsense name is actually
an anagram that solves to "no way out.".
Six months later, Ben and Zoey catch up with
each other in Chicago.
While life is going well for Ben, Zoey is
still seeking closure.
The bodies of their fellow players, she discovers,
were scattered around the world, with their
deaths made to look like accidents.
The scheme sits poorly with Zoey's sense of
justice — the world deserves to know what
really happened.
Zoey manages to convince Ben to fly to Minos'
Manhattan headquarters, the coordinates of
which she discovered hidden in the company's
logo.
They book a flight to the city — but it
turns out Minos has been watching, and is
already one step ahead.
In an epilogue, it's revealed that the people
behind Minos have designed a custom-made escape
game just for the two of them, which they
plan to install on their flight.
They will apparently have only a 4% chance
of surviving this game, which seems to be
targeting them out of pure spite.
On a monitor, a shadowy silhouette figure
overseeing the operation says it's time to
play again.
Jigsaw would be proud.
Escape Room ends with a clear tease for a
sequel — one that could demonstrate the
truly awesome reach of Minos.
It's the only time that viewers get a real
glimpse behind the curtain, and the operation
looks massive.
Dozens of people are involved with the design
of the plane escape game alone, which makes
you wonder just how deep the rabbit hole goes.
Who is the shadowy figure overseeing the game,
and what is the motivation behind the conspiracy?
Is really just for entertainment, or could
it be something more?
Whatever may come next, the track has been
laid for some truly off-the-rails insanity.
If a sequel gets the greenlight, you can count
us in the game.